hello Japan I know how popular Hugh
Jackman's fabulous dancing monkey
musical is in your beautiful country
even more popular than Deadpool which
filled me with murderous jealousy since
I couldn't beat the Claude Wonder I
decided to join him by turning my new
sequel into a musical that's right get
your tickets now for Deadpool to the
musical critics are calling so profound
it doesn't even feel like a musical
because it's not actually a musical III
might just a little message for Ryan
where is he which way should I talk to
right right there Ryan hey buddy
yeah why you man Ryan I Love You Man
I love Deadpool I can't wait to see the
movie you're one of my best friends
Blake the fam the whole thing but back
it up a little
it's just play right play a little hard
to get it's it's too much it's not sexy
am i right it's not right sorry about
okay all right I'm gonna say this once
and then delete it really quickly
Deadpool 2 is a work of genius it is
epic it is play some Deadpool I think
you have some experience with this man
is this the nolan north version yes he's
he's fantastic yeah I love nolan north
so you can do the voice for him now if
you want yeah I guess so right we could
just yeah we can just I don't want to
tell Nolan or the guys to Jean your
Deadpool ending we have to take all that
time to introduce the audience to
Deadpool the world the rules everything
how he's probably became dead for all
that stuff so we didn't you know we just
got to sort of have fun yeah we got to
just hit the ground running
[Applause]
a temple one is a love story definitely
two is there's a certainly a love story
in there but it's a family film that
sounds the go pill three is like an
alien invasion movie three my god you're
just gonna give me a [ __ ] heart
attack boy we didn't get the best
section though which is the section
where you get to beat blogan as much as
you can until you get all of that that
only happens after I fall asleep at
night yeah oh man
so that's that's not huge Jackman though
no it sure isn't that's like five foot
nine Wolvie from the comics yeah that's
real Wolverine yeah yeah Hugh Jackman
kind of outdid himself never heard of
him
can you give us a cool a send-off I
don't have a cool send-off alright no no
no Gordon hey everybody its charlie we
got a whole bunch of new Deadpool to
break down they're in full swing in the
press tour it's dropping next week if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos so I'll explain the video
schedule for when I'm posting my reviews
and all those videos next week at the
end of the video but hear like they're
just having a lot of fun with Hugh
Jackman as per usual it would be really
weird if Ryan Reynolds didn't take as
many shots a Hugh Jackman is he possibly
could while he was promoting this film
and I know there are a lot of theories
about him actually being in the movie
because they're supposed to be a secret
cameo I'll talk about that in him just
having fun playing the Deadpool game
with jacksepticeye I was totally blown
away when I saw this I was like wait a
minute what's jacksepticeye doing with
Ryan Reynolds I was like oh they're just
doing a movie integration to promote the
film jacksepticeye has a huge
international audience they used to do
this a lot more but then there was that
huge blowback and it almost seemed for a
little while like YouTube actually
declared open war on really big youtuber
starting with PewDiePie but the big deal
with Hugh Jackman in the film is I
actually don't think that he's in the
film himself like he's gone on and on
about not actually doing the character
so I think that they just found a way to
have fun with Hugh Jackman without him
having to put a costume back on because
even though he's been traveling all
around the world because greatest
showmen the Hugh Jackman film that
Deadpool is making fun of at the
beginning of this video has been blowing
up constantly for the past couple of
months
it opened really soft but then it just
blew up internationally so they've had
Hugh Jackman just traveling all over the
world to countries promoting it to keep
people going back to see it so they can
recoup their money any time a movie like
that has legs they'll keep actors going
around promoting it the same thing
happened with Titanic like that stayed
in theaters for forever so Hugh Jackman
is doing his Titanic thing for greatest
showmen naturally Deadpool is gonna take
a lot of shots at him and when he says
greatest showman is bigger in Japan he's
talking about the first step pool movie
because they haven't released Deadpool
to there yet as of me posting this video
so where is the first movie had a Hugh
Jackman mask I think they found a way to
top that without actually having Hugh
Jackman himself be in the film that was
one of my early theories when they were
first starting to make it like okay
they'll probably try to involve hugh
jackman in some way so I think they did
that though but they found a way to do
it that was funny but also didn't
require the physical presence of Hugh
Jackman himself so I don't think that he
is that secret cameo that everyone's
been talking about but there's supposed
to be some super-secret hilarious cameo
that you would never expect it as the
description implies it's not supposed to
be an actor that you would have expected
to pop up in a Deadpool movie but
someone who is a giant international
star so because the movie is coming out
in a couple days if you do get a chance
to see it early please don't spoil who
that is in the comments we'll do all
those kinds of videos after the movie
drops at the end of next week but I do
have a new juggernaut theory I was back
and forth on it until they released the
soundtrack because a lot of people saw
this trailer shot and they're like oh
man that's got to be juggernaut it looks
just like his helmet wouldn't it be
hilarious if Colossus fought the
juggernaut I was not totally convinced
and then they dropped the soundtrack for
Deadpool too if you haven't listened to
it it's hilarious they rated it ma
because the language is so hardcore but
one of the tracks specifically calls out
the juggernaut so I'm like why would
they be singing about the juggernaut in
the Deadpool soundtrack if he was not in
the movie
so based on that soundtrack it does
sound like there might be some
juggernaut in the film although I
wouldn't expect him to be a really huge
character it just sounds like they're
having fun with the x-men franchise the
way you would expect Deadpool to have
fun with it the other funny thing about
this too that I noticed while they were
playing that Deadpool game is that Brian
Reynolds is a huge Nolan North fan I
feel like most people are nolan north
deadpool fans which was just like a
little bit before the first deadpool
movie blew up and the other funny thing
about them playing this is that
currently you can't buy the game there's
like some weird rights issue where they
had to take it off of steam so even
though Deadpool as a character as a
franchise has blown up the last couple
of years there is no like really big
Deadpool game right now that they're
working on that we know of it would be
really weird if they didn't try to
capitalize on that and try to make some
new Deadpool game in the next couple of
years but what they might do is just
wait till after this Disney deal goes
through and then everyone's still
wondering what's going on with that Bob
Iger Kevin Feige have sung Deadpool's
praises I think that they don't have any
plans to mess with what they're doing
really well so Ryan Reynolds gets folded
into the group it sounds like they
intend to let him do his own thing but
Brian Reynolds makes a joke about
Deadpool 3 like oh you're gonna give me
a heart attack
he did say himself that he's not so sure
that they do Deadpool 3 they might just
do more team-up movies because that's
kind of the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like there's not
gonna be a ton of brand new solo movies
a lot of it will be like Thor Ragnarok
where you just put some other big a-list
characters in other people's films even
though the film itself might focus on a
single character you'll have varying
degrees of team-up just because they
found out that two Avengers is better
than one which I feel like is a good
thing it's just weird when you try to
think about it before you actually get a
chance to see it and it's gonna be a
while before they announced their phase
4 slate but just as I was making this
video Kevin Feige confirmed another big
phase 4 character that they're planning
on introducing so I'll do a video for
that next I should post in the next
couple of hours leave all your video
requests in the comments below and I'm
seeing the movie on Monday so my
non-spoilery Deadpool review will post
later Monday so I'll just give people
updates on when that's coming and remind
people about the video schedule and that
so click here to rewatch that video for
Ryan Reynolds
apologizing for all his terrible movies
and click here for my New Avengers 4
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]